so Michael avenatti is the least
credible person in in in the world I
think he he is it's almost it's almost
amazing how lacking incredible he is so
lacking in credibility that you won't
you have to almost doubt at this point
whether he himself exists he has he has
so little credibility that that I that
even his owning his own existence could
could now be called into question but he
is investigating investigating claims
that Tucker Carlson assaulted a gay
Latino immigrant at a restaurant in in
Virginia a month ago now that that of
course really really checks all the
boxes doesn't it a gay Latino immigrant
because that's for the left I mean
having a fox news host assault a gay
Latino immigrant that's just there that
is a headline from from heaven for them
now avenatti of course also is the guy
that investigated claims that Brett
Kavanaugh was the ringleader of a roving
band of gang rapists when he was in high
school and he determined that those
claims were true even as everyone else
who investigated them determined that
they were the insane ramblings of an
emotionally unstable woman who never
even knew Brett Kavanaugh but so the
point is you know you could be a little
suspicious of the results of his
investigation there is a video of this
altercation and if you watch the video
it shows it shows no assault occurring
all it shows is Carlson telling the man
to get the F out of here repeatedly keep
saying get the F out of here out of here
now
now so you see that you think well why
is he saying that to the guy only in the
fevered imagination of a left winger is
it at all plausible that Tucker Carlson
would have randomly started yelling get
the F out of here to someone because
they're gay and Latino right I mean if
that's how he reacts to gay people and
to Latinos there should be a video of
him screaming at somebody every day he
lives in DC for god sake he lives it he
works in media in DC because the first
time he's ever come across someone in
one of those two categories so any
rational person would see the video and
think well there
got to be more to this story and there
is Carlson last night filled in the
details he says that he Carlson was out
out to eat with his family including his
adult daughter and his and his adult son
his daughter got up to go to the
bathroom at which point the man having
seen that she was at the table with
Carlson cussed her out called her
Carlson's [ __ ] then used other
derogatory names at which point Carlson
came over with his son his son threw a
glass of wine on the guy Carlson told
him to get the F out and that's what we
see in the video now if that is what
happened and I think his story sounds
much more plausible than the other dudes
story because because we know that left
wingers do have no problem harassing the
family members of those they dislike so
that's that's a totally plausible story
and if that is what happened then
Carlson was perfectly justified in his
response he would have been justified in
fact if I if I mean if I'm annoyed at
him at all or upset with him it's only
because he didn't punch the guy in the
mouth which he would have been perfectly
justified in doing but we also to keep
something else in mind here it's just
something to remember the guy the
supposed victim although the real victim
here apparently is Carlson's daughter it
was a harassed but the guy whining about
being a victim is apparently an LGBT
activist well I guess it falls on me
sadly to be the one to point out the
that LGBT activists make up stories all
the time they are notorious for
fabricating fake hate crimes this is
some now this is something that left us
do and this is something that you know
unfortunately LGBT activists do most of
all and you can go go online and just
look up fake hate crime hoaxes you'll
find you'll find just so many of them in
fact there's a whole what am I one of my
favorite subgenres of the fake hate
crime category are the the racist or
homophobic notes that are left on
receipts I mean
are dozens of these kinds of stories
that for some reason left-wingers they
love to make up stories where a racist
or homophobic person writes a terrible
note on a receipt and leaves it for
their waiter or waitress there was a
story recently about a guy I forget what
his name was but an arab-american
waiter at a restaurant posted a picture
of a receipt of a note that was left on
the receipt from one of his tables and
and the note said but I think it says
something like we don't tip terrorists
and he posed on Facebook he goes viral
and then of course it comes out later
that he wrote the note himself it was
made up but you see that kind if there
was another one it's been a lot of these
kinds of things there have been a bunch
of someone allegedly writing n-word
where the tip line is supposed to go
there was one few years ago of a of a
lesbian woman waitress and she posts a
picture of a note on receipt the note
said we disagree with your lifestyle and
so we're not going to tip and of course
it comes out that she she made up that
story swath it's just like it's not it's
not impossible that someone could really
write a note like that but but we would
have to believe that whoever wrote that
note either has never had a
brown-skinned person as a waiter or
never had and I don't even know how they
would know that a per that your waitress
is a lesbian but they wouldn't have
never had a a female who they suspect
might be a lesbian as a waitress or they
leave notes like that all the time and
this is the first time we're seeing it
on Facebook but either way it just
doesn't it's very implausible and you
with all of these stories it shows you
something about it it reveals how the
left views the opposition where they
think of us they have this cartoonish
idea of us where they they hear a story
that Tucker Carlson because he works at
Fox News would randomly just start
cussing out a gala
you know at a bar for no reason other
than fact there's a gay latino and a lot
of left is here that story apparently
and think yeah well that makes sense
yeah sure that's exactly what they would
do no that's not what they would do it's
possible there are people in the country
who would react that way but it's it's
in it's not very plausible there's
probably another explanation so you have
the fact that this is LGBT activist
notorious for making if he comes then
you throw a Michael avenatti on top of
it and and there's just no reason to
believe their version of the story and
I'll say one more thing about this if
you harass a man's family if you harass
a man's daughter wife son you deserve
whatever comes next if he lays you got
on the floor if he breaks her nose you
deserve that because a man has the moral
right to defend his family and to teach
a lesson to anyone who would arrest them
so this guy should be thanking Tucker
Carlson for showing such restraint he
should be writing a thank-you note to
him and saying thank you for not
punching me in the nose thank you so
much for that sir that's what he should
be doing so he's not only a harasser of
women apparently but he's also rude for
not for not thanking Carlson for
reacting the way that a lot of fathers
would okay um what else
speaking of far left lunacy a far left
advocacy group called the agenda project
inappropriately creepy sounding name
just put out a in absolutely demented ad
in support of Planned Parenthood and I
wrote a piece about this supplement
daily why right now now any
advertisement supporting Planned
Parenthood is going to be demented and
horrible by definition but this one
really goes beyond what you might even
expect the ad is is titled the chosen
and it's it's a forty second video and
it opens with with and go to the go to
my article about you can see the video
itself but it opens with the inmate with
this footage of a beautiful smiling Bay
girl looking right into the camera she's
giggling and laughing and there is kind
of a lullaby music playing in the
background and then the words come up on
the screen saying she deserves to be
loved and you see that and you think
well well yes I I agree yes indeed she
deserves to be loved and then next see a
little bit more footage of the girl and
then the words come up she deserves to
be wanted and again the viewer must
concur she does indeed deserve to be
wanted and then comes the kicker she
deserves to be a choice and then were
urged to stand with Planned Parenthood
as the picture fades now let's leave
aside that the most disturbing aspect of
this video which is that somebody
apparently allowed their child to be
used for it assuming this video was was
was not made under false pretenses or
they didn't find some kind of stock
footage of a baby or something but if a
parent actually did offer up their kid
for this kind of thing then it seems
that this particular child who deserves
to be loved he's not actually loved by
her parents because no parent who loves
their child would use their child in
that way but speaking about the message
itself what makes the message itself so
barbaric so horrific is is two things
first of all and I know this shouldn't
even need to be explained but I'm gonna
explain it anyway the first problem here
is that a baby's murder
the baby's violent killing is presented
as something that the baby deserves but
then we ask what well how could a baby
deserve to be executed what in what
sense are we using the word deserved
because to deserve something needs to be
worthy of it and so we're talking about
either a reward or punishment so is the
child worthy of punishment what has she
done to deserve
this penalty or do we mean reward
deserve in the sense of reward well what
sort of reward is that to be killed I
have to wonder the makers of this video
would they like to be rewarded in a
similar way would they appreciate it if
somebody rewarded them by crushing their
skulls
aiiow soom not so if they wouldn't want
to be rewarded this way then how can
they speak for the child on this matter
now I could only assume that some text
is missing from this so I could only
assume it was supposed to say something
like she deserves to be loved she
deserves a Walden but if she isn't then
she deserves to die but that assumes
that everybody who is which which and
this is what pro-abortion people assume
and are very and are very clear about
when they you know are very upfront they
assume that everybody who isn't loved or
wanted by their biological parents would
prefer to forfeit their lives entirely
that's what they assume and you hear
this from all things well you know it's
an unwanted child what are we gonna do
with an unwanted child they're assuming
that if you are a child who is not
wanted for whatever reason by their
biological parents well there's no way
that such a child could ever go on to
lead a fulfilling and happy life but in
saying that they're ignoring the
testimonies of many millions and
millions of people who were not whose
biological parents would not or could
not care for them and yet have gone on
to be perfectly happy and yeah I'm sure
that there are some people who were born
under those circumstances and did not go
on to lead happy lives
I'm sure you could even find me people
who were born under those circumstances
went on to lead miserable lives and then
tragically killed themselves you know
I'm sure you can find me cases like that
but each individual deserves to make a
choice
between trying to live through difficult
circumstances and finding happiness and
fulfillment in the midst of it or giving
up and I certainly hope that nobody
makes a choice to give up but but once
you're an adult you know nobody can stop
you if that's the choice you want to
make the vast majority of people if
given the option will choose the former
they will choose to live through it and
find happiness in it that's what most
people do and so if we want to talk
about deserve what people deserve every
person deserves to make that choice for
themselves but but here's the real point
here that the second thing that makes
this video this this this adds so
disturbing is that it's honest okay it
shows us it doesn't show us a clump of
cells it shows us a baby and it calls
the baby she okay uses that that very
personal word there she not it not that
thing not fetus it says she it seems
almost to go out of its way to highlight
the beauty and love ability of this
adorable child so it presents human life
to us wondrous miraculous human life and
it puts that right in front of our face
and then it says yes it is good to kill
this person this is something that you
rarely see from pro-abortion people but
every once in a while you do you see
them looking straight into the dark
hideous heart of abortion advocacy and
confronting it and not flinching and
saying yep that's what I support
so that's that's that is honesty they're
being forthright about abortion kills
babies so I think we should give the
agenda project some credit for being
open and honest about about what they
believe in and what they support we
could at least give them credit for that
and then we should also condemn them for
believing and supporting something so
deranged and cruel and horrible and then
we should shut her in in terror as we
realize that many millions of Americans
agree with them but that's the main
takeaway here what does this tell you
what does it tell you that the
pro-abortion position is is C you know
seems so explicitly diabolical when it's
stated plainly and honestly that should
tell you something about the position
that you hold if if if it makes people
recoil in shock and horror at the moment
that you dropped the euphemisms well
that should really tell you something if
even people on if even some people on
your own side have this visceral gut
reaction against it when you drop the
euphemisms and take off the mask and
just show it for what it is well again
that should tell you something
all right um one more thing I wanted to
talk about this is a interesting
interesting couple interesting cases
here not completely disconnected from
what we just talked about but there was
a story this past week about a couple in
Brooklyn of course that is they're
they're swapping embryos with someone
else there's an an actress had a girl
embryo but wanted a boy embryo and then
there's a couple who had a boy embryo
but wanted a girl embryo so apparently
they are trading embryos
trading them like kids used to trade
pokemon cards okay that's what they're
the kids still trade Pokemon I have no
idea or when I was a kid we used to
trade pogs so for you know that lasted
for about six months that fed but so
their trade that's how they're trading
them now there was also a story of a
lesbian couple that's that swapped in
embryo between them they took turns
carrying in IVF embryos so yeah two of
these two of these kinds of stories in
the last couple of weeks and I think I
think what we see here especially with
the first story just focusing on that
for a moment we see the the continued
commodification of human life
this this this treating life like a like
a commodity like a thing like a like a
product an asset and when people ask me
sometimes about IVF how how I feel about
this is why I don't like it this this is
why I don't like I have yet you want to
talk about slippery slopes well it this
is a this very clear that once we start
treating human life this way you are on
that slope and we can even leave aside
the spiritual the religious aspects of
this issue those are important but we
can leave those aside and just talk
about this on on secular terms because
even if I were a secular person you mean
if I didn't believe in God I would be
saying the same thing that it is a it is
a it's a dangerous game that we play
when we go down this road of treating
people like like items you know there's
that I dealt with several months ago
someone what's supposed what's supposed
to be this this indisputable
unanswerable pro-abortion argument where
someone says well what if what if there
are a bunch of frozen embryos what if
what if there's a maybe remember when we
talk about this talked about this what
if there's a fire in an IVF clinic and
there are a bunch of frozen embryos
that are you know about to be destroyed
and there's also a two-year-old child
who happens to be in the IVF clinic as
well without his parents and for some
reason you can only save one which do
you save and they're trying to point out
that well clearly you would save the the
two-year-old child not the embryo so
obviously you're admitting in by their
version of events here you're admitting
that the child is more human than the
embryo which is which is not what you're
emitting because that would just be
scientifically inaccurate but the point
is when they when they raised that
argument what they're really doing is
raising an argument against IVF they're
raising an argument against treating
embryos like this because we shouldn't
be in a position we should never be in a
position where they're a bunch of
leftover human embryos so we have to
figure out what to do with them well you
know that hypothetical so it's only
possible to discuss that hypothetical
because this is how we treat human life
so I think it's a very I think it's a
very dangerous road to go down
and as
as science develops I mean maybe maybe a
hundred years from now maybe a hundred
years from now the the the sort of LGBT
dream will be fulfilled and maybe
they'll be able to implant some sort of
artificial uterus into a man who claims
to be a woman and then implant in embryo
into the uterus and then maybe finally
they can have their for who knows you
know with the way medical science has
developed maybe eventually they'll be
able to create that kind of freakin
Frankenstein monstrosity and bring human
life into the world that way well you
know even if you don't think we've we've
we've well on the slippery slope yet
with this stuff would you admit that
that at least is a slippery slope is
there a limit I find it kind of kind of
interesting that on the left you know
leftists are typically the ones who are
very concerned about organic they're
very concerned about doing things the
natural way doing things in accordance
with with nature and all that well why
can't we take that philosophy if we if
we could take that philosophy and apply
it to the produce section if we can
apply it if we can live by that code
when we're buying stocks of celery from
from the supermarket then maybe we
should consider the same code when we're
deciding how to bring human life into
the world you know maybe we should be
concerned about about about nature by
doing things the organic way because the
more that we treat human life this way
the more we treat it like an object it
has the effect of just debasing life and
we start
see human life more and more as as kind
of an accessory and you have a kid just
for your own sake because you want an
accessory because it's a fun thing to do
trading it back and forth you know like
it's some sort of recreational thing
it's not about the the child anymore
it's about us and then when we can get
into genetically modifying kids and you
know it's like Gattaca or something ever
seen that movie where you could decide
specifically what kind of kid you want
you can select all these different
details about them again now we have
made the child we've made this human
life into science it's completely about
us it's like we're building an accessory
for our lives rather than confronting
the sacred miracle of actual human life
all right
before I wrap up I did want to Center on
the subject of babies I did want to say
happy birthday to my to my youngest our
youngest turned 2 yesterday his birthday
was jester he watches all my videos of
course so that's why I'm saying happy
birthday to him his favorite present
that we got him by the way was a little
handheld vacuum and this kid is obsessed
with vacuums I mean he's absolutely
obsessed I think he mainly just likes
machines that make loud noises but he
definitely has a specific affection for
vacuums like he has to go hug the
vacuums in our house before he goes to
bed each night so that that's where we
are just to give you an idea of the
extent of his vacuum addiction but so
he's two now and I was thinking about
this today because people when they hear
that you have a two-year-old they'll say
oh no the terrible twos watch out watch
out for the terrible tooth and here's
the thing about that I we've already
done the terrible twos we did them times
two because our oldest are twins boy and
girls so we had two two-year-olds at the
same time that's how it works to have
twins and and so I think I could say
that the terrible twos are fake news I
totally overrated this this anti two
propaganda is ridiculous and it's it's
ageist on top of it these are these
scare tactics that people use when it
comes to two-year-olds it's it's absurd
and I want to say this to any new
parents or future parents don't worry
about - don't worry about toddler I mean
kids at two are no problem yeah they
have temper tantrums but they don't know
what's they don't know what's going on
in the world yet you can still get them
to stop crying by tickling them you
never have to really worry about when
your kids still at an age where you
could basically get them to stop crying
by tickling them or worse case giving
them a lollipop or something like that
when they're still at that age where
they can be satiated with tickles or a
lollipop it's you know it's it's not
that bad it's it's pretty good and can I
just say that I have I have known I have
known as we all have I have known
terrible people in my life okay
but none of them were - none of them
were kids at all of all the people that
I've known that I would describe as
terrible none of them were little kids I
would not describe any little kid as
actually being a terrible / it's not
possible for a little kid to be a
terrible person the terrible people are
adults so why don't we ever refer to the
terrible 40s or the terrible 30s of the
terrible 60s can you stop a 40 year old
from throwing a hissy fit by tickling
them no you can't and I've tried but
when when when you know when when kids
are upset okay it only ever stems from
from one of like four things if a little
kid is upset it's because they're tired
or it's because they're hungry or it's
because they want something like a toy
or candy something simple or they want
your attention those are really the only
four reasons why kid ever gets upset and
most of those are pretty easy to deal
it's pretty easy to you know if they're
tired you put them down if they're
hungry maybe you give them some food and
it can be it can be hard to deal with
kids when when they want one of those
things and obviously you can't always
just give them exactly what they want
when they want it or eventually they
will turn into a legitimately terrible
person and it can be annoying it can be
exhausting to deal with kids but I
wouldn't describe any of this is as
terrible you know what's terrible
maliciousness cruelty passive
aggressiveness arrogance selfish
ambition or you're just stepping over
people in pursuit of your of your aims
and these are all adult traits and worst
of all adults don't have an excuse
children have an excuse to act like
children adults don't so if we're gonna
be using this word terrible to describe
anyone I think it should be those kinds
it should be people who are capable of
actual cruelty there's never been a
little kid who's cruel that's never
happened I mean there are little kids
who could act cruel sometimes but they
don't know what they're doing that's an
adult thing
so there's my PC plea for the day let's
stop with the ageism call little kids
terrible if we're gonna call anyone
terrible it should be should be people
like me and you adults right at least we
have the capacity to be terrible all
right
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed